- So at 30, I started Wine
Library TV, YouTube blows up.
At 31 I'm on
Conan O'Brien, Ellen,
there's articles being
written about me,
now they're writing
that the business grew
from three to
60 million dollars in sales,
I'm becoming this guy.
I got so many goddamn emails
from friends in high school,
during that period
when I was showing up
in all these
magazines and TV shows,
and every single
one of them, was like
"Hey Gary, you remember
me from high school?
"Oh my God, you're so lucky."
I wrote back every single
one of them, and said,
"Let me just clarify one
thing, I'm not lucky,
"I worked. I worked every goddamn
weekend and every holiday,
"since I was 14 years old,
"so you can keep that
luck shit in your pocket."
("Inertia" by Irregular Expression)
Every day, every day
that I live my life,
I get five to 27
emails from people
that are telling me
that they are quitting,
or they should quit, or,
or are really coming
to me as a last resort
to convince them not to quit
I think a lot of times, or,
or maybe give them confirmation
that they should quit.
You know, "Hey Gary, this is Sally,
"I've been doing my
blog now for nine months
"and I'm not getting the
results that I like to see
"or that I was promised"
or that, you innuendo.
"Should I give up, like,
you know, should I,
"is my content not good enough,
"am I, is my voice
not good enough?"
And I think about it, every time,
every time I see these emails,
every time people ask me at
conferences I think about it,
I think about how sad I am
that I wasn't documenting my life,
or putting out content, or
doing The #AskGaryVee Show,
during those five and a half
years of Wine Library TV,
especially those 18 months
when nobody was watching.
You know the story
that's never told,
is the story that I was
building Wine Library
to a huge company long
before Wine Library TV,
and that the first month
that I did Wine Library TV,
was the first time that Wine Library
had not grown 30% over
the prior year's revenue.
So not only did
I have the patience
to let it play itself out and win,
it was a scenario where
I was actually losing money
by being patient.
Many of the people that are
going to watch this video
are not achieving what they want,
and are lacking the patience,
and think everything happens overnight,
and that is coming at the
cost of an unhappy life,
or no loss financially,
just loss in time.
Just coming at the
expense of Angry Birds,
or House of Cards marathons,
or the bowling team,
or hanging out with
friends and having a beer,
or reading a magazine,
or whatever the hell gets you
off and excited as a hobby.
It's coming at that expense,
it's not coming at the
expense of actual money,
or something, or pain,
or, you know,
it's coming at the
expense of a luxury.
And so to me,
the insanity, really, and
that's what I'm gonna,
you know, the disproportional
misunderstanding
that there's not a person
that you can name, not one,
there is zero people that you can name,
that had it happen overnight.
Even the nine year-old
Stevie Wonder
and six year-old
Michael Jackson,
there were years
of work put in prior
by their parents, by their uncles.
Even with the greatest
talents, even with LeBron,
he seemed like so young
when he hit the scene.
Guess what, he wasn't,
he'd already been playing
basketball for 15 goddamn years.
Even though you all say to
me like, wow, you did it,
I didn't do it, I did it
when I was 14 years old,
and 15 years old, and 16
years old, and 17 years old,
and 18 years old, and 19
years old, and 20 years old,
and 21 years old,
and 22 years old,
which are all the years
that every single weekend,
while my friends
went to the Jersey shore
and hooked up with girls,
while my friends went fishing,
while my friends hung out
and threw round the football,
and lived the leisure life,
every weekend,
every single weekend,
let me just say it one
more time, every weekend,
every day, from the
day I got out of school
to the day I went back into
school, every vacation day,
all of them, not a good
amount of them, every day,
from 7am to back
then 8pm, every day,
I was learning
the wine business.
I was honing my craft
to be a good salesman.
I was figuring out
how to be an operator.
I watched how my dad
interacted with his employees,
what I liked about it, what I didn't.
I watched my cousin Bobby
interact with the employees,
I took what I liked
from it, what I didn't.
I was 30 years old before
any of you ever saw me.
Go show me the videos
on YouTube right now,
that have me under 30.
They don't exist.
I was putting in the work, for
half my life, from 15 to 30,
where I built an actual
business. I put in actual work,
and so if you want to tell
me that every goddamn moment
of my life between 15 and
30 is an overnight success,
then knock yourself out, but
that is complete bullshit,
and every one of you know it.
And so when you email me,
that you've started this thing,
that you have the audacity
to want it to be
the rest of your life.
The audacity, really,
the entitlement,
that you think that you
should be able to do something
that you love so much,
for the rest of your life,
that makes you enough money,
to be able to do it for
the rest of your life,
that you're giving up
after four months?
That you're giving up
after two years?
As a matter of fact, every
single person watching this video
should be trying for that moment
for the rest of
their life, period.
You might hit
pay dirt at 80, and cool,
then you can really do exactly
what you love from 80 to 100.
My friends, it is a gift,
is a gift,
to wake up in the morning, and
be able to do what you want,
for the rest of your life.
The way you do that,
is by becoming a quote
unquote, "overnight success".
You know, the excuse
that everybody uses
to deploy against somebody
who's actually put in work,
for the last decade, and got
themselves into a position
where they can do
something pretty rad,
that we all think is cool,
and we all wish we could do.
You know, that thing,
the thing that you say to yourself
to make yourself feel better,
about when you're laying in bed
and playing a goddamn
game on your phone,
instead of putting in the
work to achieve what you want.
Nothing in life is free,
nothing happens overnight,
it all takes tons
and tons of work,
and tons and tons of talent,
and tons and tons of serendipity,
but my friends, luck, serendipity,
there's a forced culture within that.
You know, you'll just sit in your room,
hoping and then
something lucky happens,
nobody just knocks on
your house's door and says
"Congratulations, you've
been awarded this".
Luck comes from
being in the right spot.
I've been really lucky,
because I fucking bleed
out of my eyes every day of
my life and work my face off.
You're really lucky when
you're at that 11:30pm meeting,
where the lucky thing
happens, pretty cool,
since all you
were fucking sleeping.
I was pretty lucky, weird,
that I scheduled that meeting
'cause I did a ton of
things for 30 years,
that allowed me to
even have that meeting
in the first place, that
gave me the leverage
to have that lucky
thing that happened.
There's no overnight successes,
period, they don't exist.
Show me,
leave a comment in YouTube,
leave the name, explain
to me, tell me, show me,
let me know, show me
the overnight success,
because I'll show you you,
justifying in your brain,
something that is
just not true, period.
("Inertia" by Irregular Expression)